[Musique]
bonjour monsieur vous êtes parisien oui
alors est ce que vous pensez vous aussi
qu'il ya trop de mégots par terre dans
les rues oui ça vous dérange mes gars à
face caméra je vais juste vous mettre
les petits panneaux dans les mains c'est
ce panneau qui dit il y en a trop quand
vous appelez monsieur et kader tu me dis
que c'est bon 3 je suis avec kader khadr
qui est là pour pousser un coup de
gueule car selon lui des étrangers en
france il y en a trop oui oui je réalise
alors chavanne nous on est une
association qui milite pour la
protection des océans et notre message
c'est plus jamais ça plus jamais en
jettera papier réseaux sociaux oui je
suis d'accord 3 1
je suis avec chabane voiturier ici qui
m'a avoué en off qu'il volait dans les
voitures des clients et qui ne le ferai
plus voilà je me dis ça j'ai jamais dit
ça est-ce que tu prennes pas des mégots
par terre y en a trop mais alain bovo
web en mode saas caméra juste laisser
cette petite pancarte dans les mas 3 je
suis avec rudy goody qui aujourd'hui là
pour passer un coup de gueule car selon
lui des étrangers en france il y en a
trop tu vas lui milite pour la
protection des océans
je suppose que tu es bourg bien sûr oui
j'ai un petit peu notre marque et de
suite ma mère bouge pas j'arrête tout de
suite hein je suis avec mathieu mathieu
qui est un message très sérieux adressé
à son beau-père arrête de nick et ma
mère voilà où est ce que vous êtes pour
le partage oui oui
alors bougez pas je voulais juste le
petit panneau dans les mains nues au
partage et je reviens vous posez la
question je suis avec moussa et foot à
un jeune couple libertin la recherche
d'un nouveau partenaire
mais pourquoi tu me fais ça ce message
s'est plus jamais ça plus jamais en
jettera de patrie dans la merde tu me
dis pas seulement j'arrive tout de suite
je suis un métier dit qui est là pour
avec beaucoup de courage passer un
message à sa femme et lui dire qu'il la
trompe rap lui ouvrons j'apprends qu'il
y aura
[Applaudissements]